[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing ones wand
shops and wand makers
more specifically we're going to be
discussing every known wand maker in
harry potter
there isn't a ton of information out
there on this topic so the level of
information is going to vary from wand
maker to one to maker
but i hope you enjoy what i've put
together
considered to be a complex and
mysterious branch of magic wand making
refers to a wand maker using one decors
and words to construct ones for witches
and wizards more broadly wondermakers
can be categorized as anyone who
constructs a wand however in wizarding
society wondermakers are traditionally
witches or wizards that construct and
sell ones
the profession dates back many many
centuries and the earliest known wand
makers were said to have been druids a
druid was considered to be in celtic
times a member of the learned and
priestly class
druids considered anything with a woody
stem to be a tree
which led to them producing ones out of
things like vine
a tradition followed by wand maker
garrick ollivander in the 20th century
though druids were skilled at their
craft at this stage in history it was
still totally normal for a customer of a
one shop to bring their own core with
them
a tradition that has basically fallen
off in more recent times the first wand
making shops were known to date back to
the establishment of olivander's one
shop in 382 bc
the original ollivander the ancestor of
garrick ollivander was thought to have
come from a mediterranean country in
roman times and set up a stall in what
would eventually become diagon alley
the ollivander family revolutionized
wand making when they publicly forsook
the traditional wand-making process
which previously had witches and wizards
procure their own one decor
olivander believed this process produced
ones that were inferior in quality and
performance
which led to the family procuring all
wand components for future customers
ollivander researched the best wand
cause and would always find the best
wand wood to complement it
and where the purchaser would previously
select a wand of their choosing he began
the tradition of having the one to
choose the wizard
in large part due to the fact that the
ollivander family were so instrumental
in revolutionizing the wondermaking
process and in part due to the fact that
hogwarts students obtained ones from
olive enders many of us have been
hardwired to believe that ollivanders is
the only option when it comes to wand
shops but in truth there are in fact
many other wand makers out there in the
vast wizarding world
some of which i'll introduce you to on
today's list
today we're going to be examining all
wand makers
that is any witch or wizard that has
constructed a wand whether that be to
sell use themselves or otherwise
let's get into it
garrick ollivander well you already got
your fill on garrick olamanda and the
ollivander family in the brief
introduction on wand making above but he
still belongs on this list yes he's the
main name that comes to mind when we
think of ones but that may be for a
reason
miku gagorevic
probably the best-known wand maker
besides ollivander miku gagorovich was a
wizard famous wand maker and owner of
grogorovich zao beshtabe in europe
grogorovich was also known to sell ones
at kharkit market in london in order to
compete with ollivander
victor crown was a known proponent of
gregorovich's ones and while ollivanders
served as the primary supplier for
hogwarts students gregor of educated to
the students of dermstrang i was one of
the last to purchase a gregorovich wand
they are the best although i know of
course
that to britain set much store by
ollivander grokovic was considered to be
an expert in the highly intricate topic
of one law
however as respected and revered as he
was there was a known rivalry between
him and ollivander primarily over
differences of opinion
ollivander once remarked that
grakorovich was a fine wand maker but in
the very same sentence criticized his
styling one subject that gregorovich and
ollivander did agree on however relates
to the use of hawthorne as a wand
material
jimmy kiddle jimmy kiddle whose name was
undoubtedly inspired by tv presenter
jimmy kimmel was a british wizard and
wand maker more specifically the
proprietor of jimmy kiddle's wonderful
ones located in diagon alley
not much is known about jimmy kittle or
his approach to wand making but provided
that his shop was also located in diagon
alley and that we have never heard of
him it's likely that his ones were
inferior to ollivanders
johannes jonker johannes jonker
presumably of dutch origin was an
american muggleborn or no matchborne
wizard
that served as one of the four primary
north american wand makers in the early
20th century
his name is first shown in film in
fantastic beasts and where to find them
where he's mentioned in relation to a
wand permit application
yonker became particularly skilled at
wand banking in part due to growing up
with a cabinet maker father
growing up in a no-maj household gave
him early exposure to woodworking which
helped facilitate proper want making
later in life
it has been expressed that yonkers wands
were both in demand and easy to
recognize
in part due to his signature
mother-of-pearl inlay that they
contained despite experimenting with
various wand cores earlier in his career
yonka's preferred core was the ham of a
wampus cat
violetta beauvais
violeta pouve was another one of the
four primary north american wand makers
in the early 20th century violetta was
born in new orleans louisiana
and was known for using swamp mayhor
wood
wood from a tree native to louisiana in
all of her ones
violetta also used a one core in all of
her ones that for many years was kept a
closely guarded secret
however eventually word got out of
violetta used rugaru hair in her wand
cause
rugaru hair comes from the dangerous
dog-headed magical beast that inhabits
the us
rugaru are said to resemble werewolves
sporting the head of a dog in the body
of a human
many believed that bovais ones had a
natural affinity toward dark magic most
likely due to their rugaru core
however many great and good wizards of
the 1920s used beauvais ones including
macoosa president seraphina pickery
thiago quintana
thiago quintana was an american wizard
that also served as another of the four
wand makers who served north america in
the early 20th century
quintana's ones were said to produce
spells of force and elegance created
with a single spine taken from a white
river monster a magical fish-like
creature native to arkansas
after quintana's death it has been
expressed that no other wand makers
continued with the use of white river
monster spine cores the primary reason
for this being that no one else knew how
to lure the creatures
jacoba wolfe jacoba wolf was an american
witch in the last of the four primary
wand makers that served north america
during the early 20th century
wolff was said to be of choctaw descent
a group of native american people
originally from the southeastern part of
the united states
wolf produced intricately carved ones
and would often use thunderbird tail
feathers as cores
thunderbird tail feathers come from the
famously powerful magical beast the
thunderbird a large cousin of the
phoenix that's capable of causing storms
thunderbird ones are thought to be
incredibly powerful but difficult to
master and are often sought after by
those interested in transfiguration
arturo cephalopos
arturo cephalopos was a wondermaker in
the 19th century who competed with
garrick ollivander's grandfather
gerbelled olivander
goebbel dollavander claimed that silver
lime a fashionable wand material at the
time had an association with divination
a claim that arturo vehemently denied
going as far as to state that the claim
was a falsehood circulated by merchants
like gerbild olivander who have
overstocked their workshops with it and
hope to shift their surplus
garrick ollivander otherwise known as
the ollivander we know best has since
referred to cephalopos as an ignoramus
that apparently ended up going out of
business gosmer akajor cosma akshore was
a french wizard and wandmaker who ran
baguette magic de cosme akajor in place
cachet paris
la cajon is mentioned in the crimes of
grindelwald but unfortunately we don't
know anything about his process for
creating ones
and that concludes the list of wand
makers who work as well wand makers
however it should be noted that some
other witches and wizards outside of the
ones who sell ones have been reported as
having made ones as well
these witches wizards include izoltser
and james steward who were able to
create a wand for chadwick boat out of
serpent's horn and prickly ash salazar
slytherin who purportedly created his
own wand out of snake wood and basilisk
corn and antioch peverell who according
to dumbledore created the elder wand and
that's it for this video if you enjoyed
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel
did you know about these other wand
makers leave a comment down below
until next time remember
it takes a great deal of bravery to
stand up to our enemies but just as much
to stand up to our friends
you